how do you know you have a good concept
for a movie
I asked my manager
I don't know I think I do have to kind
of bounce that idea off of people like I
always think I have a great concept but
from what I've learned is I have to let
that settle a little bit and then really
kind of just keep thinking about that
idea
and and you know now I have a manager so
he will tell me if he's seen like a
thousand of these ideas already or not
um but yeah
so do you think that you also have to
know for yourself though I mean what if
your manager says oh this is great but
you don't feel committed to the work
yeah I mean first and foremost you have
to believe in it right
um but for me I always believe in my
concept so my problem is more like
I always believe in it so I need
somebody else to tell me if it's
actually not that great
and not everything my manager would say
I agree with so
and there are some
well one film that I wanted to do
um where I know it's a great
um story and concept so that's the one
I'm gonna do
not as a live action
oh with Unreal Engine yeah you're gonna
do it with
like using real people in real time okay
yeah
do Writers come up with ideas or are
ideas just revealed to them
I think the ideas are revealed
because you know and that goes into like
creativity right like where does
imagination come from
and I don't think you know
it'll be very egotistical to say that oh
I'm the one that comes up with an idea
because
if you think about thought like thoughts
thoughts just pop into your head
you know and sometimes just random
thoughts would come from out of nowhere
so it's like where do those thoughts
come from it's come from the same Source
where you know your imagination your
creativity will come from so it's really
just about you like
capturing that and being open to it when
it arrives
yeah I think there's a book thoughts or
things
and so yeah just that it's thoughts or
energy of course and yeah that we could
be you know you know when they they we
pick up things that are in the Zeitgeist
or whatever it's it's you know this
energy that we're tapping into yeah
why do you have a hard time coming up
with ideas
so I think
I I don't have a hard time coming up
with ideas because I get a bunch of
ideas all the time but it's really about
me choosing the right idea that I'm
interested in
and
a lot of times I just have to you know
let it marinate a little bit
um until I I it's the ideas I keep going
back to those are the ones that
ultimately I'll write a script for
do you think in some ways you might be
stopping yourself from coming up with
ideas or or maybe too critical judging
them too much
I think
I think a lot of times I come up with an
idea that is really just
there's not enough substance to it you
know it's just like a gimmick idea like
oh what if you know one day you wake up
and
the world is upside down
say okay then what like what is your
actual story like who's your character
because there has to be more than just
like the concept and a lot of times I
get stuck on that which is like I have
like maybe a gimmicky kind of idea or
interesting idea but it's like what is
the actual story
um so that's usually where I get stuck
like I need that story
um to fit into that idea
so it's it's one thing to have like a
cool movie idea we talked about one that
I had off camera but it's another
actually flush it out and spend time on
yeah like what what is the actual story
like what is it really about
um
you know the character and the journey
of this character
um so a lot of times like that takes a
lot of time to really
bring out and for me it takes like
multiple rewrites
um before I actually see what the story
is about
oh so you may not even have an idea of
the ending or the whole character Arc
until you actually start the writing
process I mean I might have kind of an
idea of what the ending is going to be
like
but sometimes I have to just start
writing and then
more of it will come to me like in the
middle of typing as I'm typing a scene
out
it'll start going in a different
direction and I'll just okay I'll go in
that direction and then
you know later when I look back on that
scene I'm like oh wow this is like what
the movie's about like it kind of just
came out you know as I was typing it
how do you know an idea is yours but you
were the one to bring it to life
I don't think I don't think I'm the one
to I don't think any ideas are mine I
think they come from this other realm
this other place
and
and I'm just the one that's like
interpreting that idea and bringing it
out expressing it
and that's why you know a lot of times
they say
there's no original idea anymore like
every story has been told already but
it's like how you tell that same story
because everything really comes from
just like a human nature aspect
um
but we retell it in the context of like
a modern society or retell it in the
context of a science fiction world
so yeah
if an idea comes too easy
do you trust it
yeah I think you know I think if it's a
good idea
um it doesn't matter how this idea comes
because
if it pops in your head and it's and
you'll know it when it's like oh wow
there's there's something to this
you know like it speaks to you
um
but it doesn't matter how it came about
you know and a lot of times for me I
have to put myself in um an environment
where the ideas can come
so for me it's like as I'm writing
ideas will come to me so that's like a
meditative State as I'm writing or I go
for a walk or if I travel somewhere or
by you know go to a park and just sit
there
um
surfing like you know just gotta find a
place where your thoughts can move
freely and you're able to really
be in tune with that
do you think there's a correlation
between sort of like navigating waves
and and thoughts and writing is there
like a
hmm I mean I've always thought of
Surfing as a great
analogy for life
so I think there's something to what you
just said
because the waves will keep coming right
but you kind of have to be ready first
of all for the wave and second of all
you have to pick the right wave like you
try to paddle for every wave
you know you know just eat it maybe on a
field goal but you got to pick the right
wave the right shape and you have to be
in the right position to get that wave
and then you'll ride like a really nice
wave
because you said that some of these
ideas were just gimmicks so is that
almost like you're also picking the wave
you're trying to decide what's what's a
gimmick and what's actually a good
yep okay all right so I just too glassy
you can't I don't know I don't know the
surfing metaphor okay
is that something that you really took
took partake is that something you did a
lot when you were in San Diego you were
surfing um in San Diego but also out
here
yeah I live pretty close to the beach so
I can surf I'm like 10 minutes from the
beach
is there a difference in the in the San
Diego surf Community versus LA
yeah I think La they're a little bit
um more aggressive
oh really in terms of like getting their
little spot in the water yeah yeah oh
wow okay San Diego's more like hey man
yeah it's all good okay yeah I think
that's sort of a metaphor for the area
too yeah you know but um do you prefer
being around them an energy where you
kind of have to fight for your spot or
do you like to be
more in a harmonious I I tend to stay
away from the other Surfers I mean I
really don't care if the waves are good
in one spot I'll be where those waves
are but generally like and I think for
most Surfers you kind of want to have
your space
right most people probably don't go into
the water just to
you know be social it's more about
and finding something in them some kind
of inner thing but do you see that same
analogy in in the film world because you
know there's a lot of judgment on oh
well this film and these credentials
from this Festival do you think you take
that same like I just want to find my
little spot
in the film world and just make my
movies
yeah I mean
I really don't like going out to the
film events and you know doing that
whole thing
um and I do think there is a lot of like
judgment and
this idea of like oh they got an award
and this film didn't get an award
um
like you know with the Oscars and all
that so
for me now
I just want to focus on you know why I
initially got into filmmaking which is
like to be creative to tell stories and
that's the part that I like I don't like
the aspect of like outside validation
and having festivals or like critics
um approve your film as like a good film
or not you know you can put out to the
audience and the audience can tell you
if like they like it or not
I guess that goes back to the original
question
when we first asked you we first started
rolling which was why do you stop or or
why did you stop chasing success
which sort of ties into that maybe yeah
yeah
festivals are great for watching other
films sorry yeah I love festivals but
you know you gotta recognize
them for what they are which is it's
just a celebration of films it's not
like a place where you get validated
although it's become that in the
industry for sure especially with places
like Sundance or um you know
can but yeah you kind of have to I mean
at least for me you know maybe some
other filmmakers are really gunning for
that but for me
um
like I'm just really focused on creating
something that is interesting for me
um and something that I think a specific
audience might like
that's fascinating about the surfing the
nature of the mindset
in one area versus another
yeah there's a lot of analogy with
surfing and life
have you ever been told to like you're
in my little area
um I'm trying to catch this wave or I'm
trying to do that mostly most times
people will just um
you know if you drop in on someone when
they're surfing or they'll drop in on
you like that's usually when there's
some conflict that happens
um but you know I've definitely had some
you know run-ins with
Surfers but I think after a few
experiences like that it's like hey I'm
just trying to go out and surf I don't
wanna
go out Surf and then come back feeling
like I just had argument with someone
sure you know because then both people
don't feel great for the rest of the day
I'll rather just like ignore you if you
drop in I'll be like okay I'll just
paddle away I don't care you know what
does that mean to drop in um like if
somebody's on the way ready and then you
paddle for the wave and kind of like
drop it in front of them like cut them
off
ah okay drop in
got okay interesting how common is it
for you to work on a movie idea only to
abandon it months later you said
sometimes you you get it out of your
system when you write a script
yeah
um I've definitely done that
a lot I would say
um I've had a few scripts where I wrote
maybe a draft or two and then kind of
just left it
um
yeah I would say
a lot of projects kind of go through a
few drafts and then get left aside
so
yeah but that's kind of like my process
like I have to write that story for me
to realize oh this is like wasn't really
it you know
um and and for me like it's the process
of discovery
like what was I interested in with that
story once I write it then
maybe there wasn't something that was
that interesting anymore so I go to the
next thing
how long does it take you to write the
first draft
it could be like
well because it takes some time for me
to get to that first draft like I first
have to
um like write a treatment or an outline
and that process would take a while it
could take like two months maybe but to
write the actual draft once I have my
outline it could just be like maybe a
couple weeks
so it's worth it to you to spend that
much time and decide okay I've gone
through a couple drafts actually not
sure about this story
it's okay yeah yeah for me um I like the
process of writing so
you know I don't mind doing that and
I am getting better as a writer when I
do that it's like practicing right it's
like you're going to the gym so
you know why do people I don't go to the
gym I hate going to the gym but it's
kind of like that idea you're just
exercising your muscles
um
so that you can write the next
script that will be you know a great
script that you're really passionate
about